what do you think is the purpose of
reality why does reality exist
jesus um
why does reality exist
i don't i mean i think first of all i
think we see
i'm not sure that i know how to answer
that question exactly um
i think uh we see
reality is so subjective we see such a
narrow piece of what is happening so
you know our reality is a tiny little
slice of what's actually
happening um i mean i think the hum
like i know one of the topics that you
love to get into in the name of your
uh podcast you know simulation um
both ray uh kurzweil and peter diamandis
believe
that we are living in a simulation i'm
not sure that i necessarily
am there yet but i also find
uh the human body to just be
just mind-blowing like how is it
possible
um and you know the world that we've
been able to create the things we've
been able
uh to figure out but really just like
the human body
to me how how we operate and
the complexity uh it's just so
extraordinary um and so anyway that's a
that's a bit of a tangent but
i find that just really miraculous and
you know i i don't know i'd be
interested to hear how you answer that
question no one's ever
uh asked me that before and i think i
haven't clearly formulated a great
answer other than i believe we see such
a narrow
piece of it what it serves as that's
actually a key that was actually a
massive key because it
triggered something interesting which
was that
the same way that we only see the
the 700 to 400 nanometer-ish on the
electromagnetic spectrum in terms of
visual uh
it's fascinating because that similar
analogy can be drawn to
our universe out of the multiverses
right
that was an interesting one that sparked
from right from that the parallel
parallel realities that are all taking
place you know at the same time
and what's going on with quantum and the
entanglement i mean it's like
there's a lot of stuff that is like
pretty
mind-expanding you know as you try to
put your uh
your arms around it may i may i also um
please
uh
the nomenclature of simulation is
a is something that makes
there's like so many different i guess
ways to interpret the hermeneutics of
what simulation means
to use a spiritual word to describe what
a modern enter
to describe an interpretation of a
modern idea
but the thing is is that
what would
if we reverse engineer a godhead right
in this case the godhead we have to make
a hypothesis about the godhead as
what like what the point of reality is
right and then the hypothesis might be
something like i've been using three
words to try and describe it which is
consciousness exploring
infinity so that there's an
infinite amount of states of
phenomenology and
qualia and experience that exist
and that consciousness is just eternally
undergoing the explorative process
and it's doing it cyclically which is
why like sir roger penrose
who won the nobel prize in physics in
2020 believes in cyclic cosmology
not in the sense that we come back to
this exact same reality that's boring
we're never coming back to this exact
same reality but that we've been
exploring reality designs and different
vehicles to put ourselves into this is
four
limbs two eyes carbon-based dna encoded
but you have to be like walt disney and
imagine
all these other different soul vehicles
and realities that exist
and then what you can do is you can
begin thinking like okay well
maybe it makes sense when i hear the
words you know singularity is near when
i hear
what uh when i experience vr ar
mixed realities when i see the bio and
neurotech
additions that are being made to to
people when i see
artificial general intelligence being
developed like maybe it is
that the synthesis of those things is
called the metaverse
and that just like we are going to
slowly be in
in immersing ourselves more and more in
indistinguishable
virtual worlds that maybe this already
is one
of those that we came from that and
we're going back into it
and it's cyclical in the sense that the
godhead is the metaverse
and that we're going to immerse
ourselves in more of these infinite
explorations of realities
and our consciousness and our energy
will be you know
transition and be rebirthed and yeah
that that makes sense to me actually
um you know i don't know that i
necessarily believe
uh in god
like is this a part of a master
orchestration or is this um
you know biol compounds chemicals
nutrients coming together and evolution
going on this fantastical
journey i do believe though that i do
believe in consciousness
and that the consciousness continues on
which then causes you to think about
okay what is that this idea of a
metaverse and what do you
do transition into something else or um
you know what is that that kind of after
this piece is gone you know what is the
what is the next iteration i don't you
know it's still evolving in my head
uh what that is but but the scenario you
paint um
makes sense to me and kind of resonates
and then another question to ask then
would be something like
will you be a both a
designer and a player in those games
that we're talking about the continued
exploration
and is the answer i hard to know but i
would hope so you would hope so so
i would love i would hope so and so then
my my next
sort of point then would be that if all
eight billion people
are undergoing both being the designers
and the players in those games
then we are the designers and players of
of this
right and so then when people say the
word
god we are that we
are this this is all that right
and that's what the perennial spiritual
traditions have been saying the mystic
traditions
over 5000 years from ancient egypt and
mesopotamia all the way up until
and in this valley with the vedic rishis
all of them have been saying and through
zoroaster and the axial age and the
explosion of all the ones that exist
today
that that common perennial spirituality
is that my awareness
my consciousness my beingness my is-ness
my existence
is god and that it's eternal it's
infinite it's cyclic
it's exploring and that that is it
and that now we take science and we
simulation theory
and we just leverage sort of the
technological
protocols that enable us to go into the
next
immersion that's a hypothesis
so how do you think technology then
does does technology have a role in that
technology isn't really needed
right i guess for you to try for you to
transcend and for this
evolution to to continue for you to go
into kind of your next
existence technology i guess changes the
game
changes the experience at least in in
this uh
universe well
how would the question would be how
would uh
humans on the planet uh
if meditating on mountaintops and not
building
artificial general intelligence how
would they undergo the metaverse
recursion would be a question to ask
well is it not just a natural
is it a natural big bang and big crunch
that's that's
and if it is the death rebirth if it is
like
yes it may be both in a sense
that it's uh are you saying actually
that it's technology that enables you to
do that it's the evolution of technology
that ultimately will allow us
to oh interesting okay i took it to be
that it was just consciousness you know
the energy
of our existence that's why i was gonna
say it's both in that sense because the
energy of the existence is what enables
the process
as we build the technological
infrastructure right then
enables us to go through the whole cycle
into a different explorative
interest so maybe back to this existence
or a rebirth here but more likely you
think
a rebirth someplace else something along
the lines of like
we're so like imagine like that whole
electromagnetic spectrum visuals that
you brought up earlier i think that's
that's so spot on regarding
our imagination and creativity being
just just
quelled to such a small tiny degree
there's so much potential that exists
for universes uh and
conscious agents in those universes
because i mean
just go look at the catalog of video
games that exists right now there's so
many different
creative universe designs that people
are making but one of the things that
seems to be
a property that we talked to david
johnson dj about on the show who's a
simulation designer in virtual worlds
just yesterday on the show that one of
the things that seems to be most common
is this
three space using x y and z
in this three space format because it
sort of
comes from some sort of an origin zero
point and then has these three
axis axes which then enable
the sort of space phenomenon
to occur yeah interesting and so that
might be a more
common property of the universes that we
design
and then time seems to be one that is uh
you know this is one thing that many
people can't handle simultaneity
you can both simultaneously see the good
in the us and in china you can
simultaneously see the good in
indigeneity
and modernity in the left and the right
and conservatives and liberals in the us
in this case it would be can you
literally
hold the fact that you are both
eternal infinite biologically at
the same time as you can hold finite
biological time
where you literally have a north star
and that you're in like
fun pursued and like i think the answer
to that is yes yes
i'm not there yet but i definitely know
some
people who really are there and believe
that
you know in their core and it's amazing
to see and they
work very hard in this life in this
existence to optimize it
and be the best that they can do but
also have kind of a
a much longer game and broader
perspective
uh which is really beautiful and freeing
and energizing in
in many ways yes yes yes i love that and
i hope
i hope that one of the things that can
come from
our dance is that
if i can come and help
some of what both the
founders of the kitty hawk companies are
doing and
some of the a360 community as well
if i can come and help be of service to
what topics we've been talking about to
help
people become
more ethical moral spiritual
philosophical artistic
as they do their science their
engineering um
and their actualization of their
business entrepreneurial goals into the
world
that that is like definitely one of my
main like loves and passions and roles
and i would love to feature more of them
i love that i very much appreciate that
would love to love to figure out how we
can integrate that more into into what
we're doing
hell yeah hell yeah well i love it what
a what an epic program